[Musica]
io sono sempre stato una persona molto
ambiziosa sempre preoccupato di avere
qualcosa in più qualcosa in più che la
vita mi dava oppure addirittura di
prendere qualcosa che la vita non voleva
darmi e sono sempre stato convinto che
per essere felice doveva avere successo
successo al lavoro successo nella vita
uguale felicità nella prima parte della
mia vita io sono stata una persona molto
egoista molto incentrata su me stesso
tutte le relazioni che avevo le persone
che incontravo le cose che facevo erano
sempre finalizzate a qualcosa e quel
qualcosa era un mio guadagno personale
qual è il problema Il problema è che
quando se egoista quando il faro del
film della tua vita è puntato solo su di
te prestì il fianco all'insorgere e al
proliferare di emozioni negative
emozioni negative come per esempio
invidia gelosia quando confronto la mia
vita con quella degli altri che hanno
quel Luna cosa che io non ho e che
proprio però disperatamente voglio e
quindi sono infelice oppure un'altra
emozione negativa un'azione in realtà
negativa è quella che io scherzo sempre
Dico il vero sport nazionale dell'Italia
che non è il calcio ma è lamentarsi
lamentarsi delle cose
qual è il problema di quando noi
proiettiamo la nostra vita in relazione
agli altri che è talmente facile davvero
facile trovare un alibi no ci deve
responsabilizziamo relativamente al
trovare soluzioni i nostri problemi
perché se non è colpa mia perché devo
essere io a risolvere questo problema vi
faccio alcuni esempi quando io sono
andato all'università il primo anno di
università sono stato a tanto così da
lasciarla perché non riuscivo a passare
sto maledetto esame di geometria Eppure
vedevo alcuni colleghi e compagni di
corso che ritenevo meno intelligenti di
me che l'hanno passato con facilità E di
chi era la colpa del liceo che non mi
aveva preparato bene
oppure quando andavo alle superiori non
avevo molta fortuna con le ragazze di
chi era la colpa delle ragazze che non
vedevano Quanto ero bello simpatico
intelligente Oppure nelle mie prime
avventure professionali io ero
sistematicamente bypassato quando c'era
una promozione un aumento Insomma
un'opportunità E perché questo perché i
capi non capivano il mio valore La colpa
era sempre fuori ora il mondo in cui
viviamo Oggi tutti noi più o meno
viviamo in qualche maniera due vite la
nostra vita reale e la nostra vita sui
social media qual è il problema che la
gente sui social media anche quindi va a
Popolare i nostri Feed posta sempre la
parte migliore della sua vita la cena
nel ristorante stellato la vacanza alle
Maldive mentre noi magari siamo sul
divano a scofanarci un vasetto di gelato
da soli no E quindi noi tendiamo a
confrontare la nostra vita reale che è
sempre per definizione imperfetta e alla
quale sempre per definizione manca
qualcosa con la vita falsa col top cento
della vita delle persone che fanno parte
della nostra cerchia di conoscenze non è
un caso che oggi sentiamo parlare molto
spesso di fenomeni come il Quiet
quitting o la greiters Nations quindi
dove le nuove generazioni si stanno
rendendo conto che il lavoro non può
essere il fine della loro vita è
piuttosto che fare un lavoro che non gli
piace si dimettono anche senza
alternative Queste sono le grandi
dimissioni oppure poiché Ovviamente la
vita costa quindi muto l'affitto le
bollette costano sto lì e sono più o
meno un Androide che fa quello che deve
dalle 9 alle 18 per portare a casa la
pagnotta però non puoi essere felice
quando vivi così quello che ho scoperto
in anni più recenti è che grandi
psicologi e Filosofi mi dicono che per
fortuna non solo io vivevo così vivevo
in maniera egoista incentrata su me
stesso Carl Jung che è stato appunto uno
psicologo e filosofo svizzero dice che
l'essere umano nella prima parte della
sua vita è incentrato su se stesso per
un semplice motivo evoluzionistico
Durante l'infanzia noi siamo preoccupati
a capire che siamo esseri umani durante
l'adolescenza Siamo preoccupati a
trovare il nostro sistema valoriale I
nostri obiettivi a definire la persona
che vogliamo essere e poi nei primi anni
da adulto sostanzialmente
ci preoccupiamo di trovare e definire
quale vogliamo essere il nostro ruolo in
società Per fortuna però a un certo
punto fra i 30 e 40 anni di solito
succede un evento che cambia
completamente questa prospettiva questo
evento tipicamente accade al nostro
esterno no E può essere sono eventi
tipicamente negativi parliamo magari di
una grave malattia la perdita di un caro
oppure anche positivi come la nascita di
un figlio perché improvvisamente per la
prima volta nella nostra vita diventiamo
consapevoli che non siamo immortali la
nostra vita ha una fine prima o poi
finirà e quindi questo sposta
leggermente quel faro che prima era
puntato su di noi anche sulle persone
che stanno intorno
nel mio caso è stato Scoprire di che
sarei diventato papà a 36 anni ho
scoperto che sarei diventato papà e mi
sono fatto un esame di coscienza Ho
detto ma io sono una persona pronta per
essere padre ma io creerò un ambiente
ospitale nel quale posso far crescere
mia figlia e io badate bene Avevo una
vita che guardarla da fuori era una di
quelle su Facebook perché vivevo a
Londra vivevo con la mia allora
fidanzata adesso moglie eravamo
felicissimi
Lavoravo per una grande azienda avevo un
buon stipendio quindi andava tutto bene
eppure C'era un rumore di fondo che mi
dava fastidio che ogni tanto entrava
nella mia vita senza che io veramente
facessi niente per farlo entrare e mi
dava fastidio ricordo un episodio molto
chiaro eravamo in vacanza appunto con la
mia fidanzata a Orlando in Florida a
Disneyland cinque giorni consecutivi
dentro i parchi della Disney la vacanza
tu date più bella che io abbia mai fatto
durante quella vacanza riceve una mail e
questa mail mi specifica quelle che
sarebbero state le promozioni per
l'azienda nella quale lavoravo per
l'anno in corso e in questa mail c'era
scritto che un mio collega che io
ritenevo un perfetto incapace era stato
promosso e io No ora non vi dico che mi
ha rovinato la vacanza perché sarebbe
mentire Ma vi posso garantire che mi ha
rovinato la giornata e io dicevo Ma è
possibile che un evento della mia sfera
professionale vada a impattare in questa
maniera nel mio umore qua in Florida
mentre sono a Disneyland non è possibile
e quindi ho fatto un ragionamento Ho
capito ok Io ho queste emozioni negative
Devo capire come toglierle le emozioni
negative sono come un fuoco come si fa a
spegnere il fuoco con l'acqua sì altro
modo è togliergli l'aria perché se gli
togli l'ossigeno il fuoco si spegne
allora ho capito che io senza rendermene
conto avevo dei comportamenti
assolutamente normali che andavano a
nutrire questa negatività per esempio
quando io ero al sabato mattina a casa
da solo magari alle 11 della mattina un
po' annoiato così Cosa faccio cosa non
faccio videogiochi apro la dispensa
patatine biscotti caramelle oppure
quando ero in metropolitana quando ero
in treno cosa facevo apro il social
media e guardo quello che vi ho detto
prima oppure ancora domenica mattina
sabato sera hai fatto tardi cosa fai Ti
svegli tardi alle 11 alle 12 ti svegli
sei in mezzo rimbambito poi sei
rimbambito tutto il giorno poi la sera
non hai sonno quindi non vai a letto
presto lunedì mattina ti svegli alle
7:00 per andare a lavorare Sei
rimbambito anche il lunedì erano dei
comportamenti assolutamente normali che
però mi rendevano negativo alimentavano
la negatività alimentavano questo senso
di disagio che io avevo e che permeava
anche una vita che io stavo lavorando
sodo per costruire e cercavo di appunto
godermi e non ci riuscivo a pieno quindi
che cosa ho fatto ho iniziato a studiare
ho iniziato a dire ma come faccio io a
togliere l'ossigeno come faccio io a
rimuovere questi comportamenti Quali
sono i comportamenti che devo rimuovere
e quindi ho iniziato a leggere libri di
crescita personale podcast siti web
eccetera eccetera e ho imparato una
serie di cose che mi hanno permesso di
costruire un sistema operativo basato su
tre pilastri che mi hanno permesso di
vivere una vita molto più equilibrata il
primo di questi è la disciplina perché
vi parlo di disciplina perché ho
scoperto che quello che mangi le
abitudini che hai il loro a cui ti
svegli la qualità del tuo sonno
impattano il come tu ti senti e
impattano il come tutti i Proietti nei
confronti delle altre persone quindi ho
preso in mano la mia alimentazione ho
preso in mano diciamo il mio benessere
psicofisico iniziato a fare esercizi
tutti i giorni ginnastica perché volevo
avere un corpo in forma e questo mi ha
portato ad avere dei livelli energetici
alti durante tutta la giornata Io non
avevo la pausa l'abbiocco post pranzo
per esempio è sparito ho cominciato a
sentirmi talmente bene talmente carico
talmente positivo che i risultati a
lavoro hanno cominciato ad aumentare
cominciamo a performare di più e
lavoravo meno lavoravo meno e producevo
di più oltretutto siccome stavo molto
bene con me stesso le persone venivano
maggiormente attratte a me perché
ovviamente prima continuavo a lamentarmi
di tutto continuavo a guardare ma lui a
questo io no eccetera eccetera e non è
piacevole stare vicino a una persona
così invece quando sei positivo
tendenzialmente le persone vengono a te
e quindi ho cominciato a scoprire anche
il piacere di essere gradito di andare a
fare molti più pranzi coi colleghi di
andare a fare gli aperitivi alla sera e
questo ha causato un'accelerazione della
mia carriera Perché lavoravo meglio
risultate migliori se hai quello
simpatico tipicamente quando adesso
c'era la promozione si ricordavano di me
molto più rispetto a prima
questo ci porta al secondo Pilastro del
sistema operativo che ho costruito che
sono le relazioni no come vi dicevo io
ho passato gran parte della mia vita
praticamente a girare con uno smartphone
in mano in modalità selfie Mi guardavo
faccio finta di guardare me stesso e poi
improvvisamente ho scoperto che c'era il
bottone sotto quello con le freccette
che ti permette di abilitare la
telecamera sul retro quindi che cosa ho
fatto siccome appunto le persone
venivano me Io invece di preoccuparmi
del mio tornaconto Ho girato la
telecamera e ho detto cosa posso fare io
per te come posso aiutarti e quindi
manifestando curiosità e interesse nei
confronti delle persone con le quali
interagivo
ho iniziato a crescere ancora più
velocemente perché imparava un sacco di
cose queste persone avevano tantissimo
da dare ma io prima ero preoccupato solo
di quello che io potevo prendere oppure
di quello che io dovevo dire invece
adesso per la prima volta stavo zitto
ascoltando e tra l'altro ascolto attivo
non con lo smartphone in mano ascolto
con il corpo non solo con le orecchie
ascolto con gli occhi faccio domande
voglio capire questo mi ha portato a
crescere ancora di più e stavo imparando
talmente tanto che ho detto cavoli Qua
non mi ricordo niente Cioè sto imparando
talmente tanto che è più di quello che
io onestamente riesco a ricordare e
quindi mi è venuta questa idea l'idea di
condividere tutto quello che imparavo in
pubblico ho scritto un libro Ho fatto un
podcast che faccio tuttora un canale
YouTube una newsletter questo lo faccio
con due finalità La prima è quella di
dire Ma se io imparo così tanto È
ingiusto che tutto quello che imparo e
che vedo che funziona rimanga solo utile
a me
e quindi io lo rendo pubblico in maniera
che chiunque possa trarre uno stimolo Da
quello che ho imparato io In quella
particolare situazione la seconda
finalità forse ancora più importante
della prima è che dato che metto tutto
fuori tutto disponibile a tutti permetto
a chiunque di darmi un feedback
direttamente a capire se sbaglio quindi
invece di Ah io sono convinto Sono un
fenomeno faccio questo se uno dopo una
settimana mi dice che sbaglio perfetto
ho corretto e quindi evito di perdere
tempo a fare la cosa per la quale mi
sento fenomeno E questo porta tutto
questo gruppo di persone a crescere
molto più velocemente perché di ogni
cosa prendiamo sempre la versione
migliore
il terzo Pilastro del mio sistema
operativo è un pilastro che ho scoperto
grazie a questo mio lavoro di
condivisione ed è la gratitudine perché
io per gran parte della mia vita
soprattutto le persone che facevano
parte della mia cerchia di affetti più
intimi non li ho mai Ringraziate nel
senso una persona se ci pensate più
fanno parte della nostra cerchia di
affetti moglie e marito Madre Padre
litighiamo per scontati ed è sbagliato
perché quando io condividevo queste cose
su internet ricevevo dei messaggi dai
meriti sconosciuti che mi dicevano
Davide tu mi hai cambiato la vita gli ho
detto No la vita te la sei cambiata tu
Sì ma tu mi hai dato lo stimolo e io
dicevo Wow questo momento di gratitudine
questa mail che mi arriva mi dà una
gioia che non c'è soddisfazione
professionale che possa paragonarsi a
questo momento e io sono colpevole di
non regalare questo momento a tutte le
persone che mi fanno sentire così con
quello che fanno E con quello che hanno
fatto per me e quindi ho iniziato a
mettere enfasi sul momento della
gratitudine ho ringraziato i miei
genitori ma li ho ringraziati a 41 anni
per la pazienza che hanno avuto quando
ne avevo 5 e non l'avevo mai fatto prima
ci siamo messi a piangere tutti By The
Way adesso se vado avanti a parlarne Le
piego anche adesso OK È un momento
fondamentale dove sostanzialmente
diciamo Io non do per scontato quello
che tu hai fatto Io so che tu hai fatto
fatica e lo apprezzo e questo lo faccio
di nuovo tutti i giorni con tutti con
mia moglie con le mie figlie e Faccio
del bene a me e Faccio del bene
all'altra persona non dandola per
scontata la gratitudine poi deve
estendersi alla persona che più
facilmente tendiamo a ignorare ovvero
noi stessi
non siamo capaci di apprezzare quello
che abbiamo non siamo capaci di
apprezzare quello per cui lavoriamo Noi
spendiamo un sacco di tempo in ufficio
un sacco di tempo un sacco di fatica per
far andare avanti in relazioni nel senso
i matrimoni figli padri madri gli
vogliamo bene dell'anima ma le relazioni
richiedono lavoro facciamo fatica eppure
non siamo in grado di apprezzare la
fatica che abbiamo non siamo in grado di
darci una pacca sulla spalla Io faccio
sempre questa metafora quando faccio
coaching e dico e come se tu scagli una
montagna no e arrivi su cos'è la prima
cosa che fai tiri fuori il telefono e
fai una foto no la prima cosa che devi
fare è quella che avrebbe fatto tuo
nonno devi chiudere gli occhi devi
sentire il vento devi sentire il sole
devi sentire i profumi suoni
devi vivere quel momento Devi guardarti
indietro e devi dire Wow Quanta strada
che ho fatto sono bravo è un momento è
un istante poi la foto la fai e quando
la guarderai fra 1 o 2 anni tre anni
rivivrai quel momento ma se non l'hai
vissuto non puoi riviverlo e quindi
dobbiamo essere capaci di apprezzare
quello che siamo stati in grado di
costruire io oggi rimango una persona
tendenzialmente ambiziosa e voglio
sempre avere quell' 1-2% che non ho Però
a differenza di una volta mi preoccupo
anche e ringrazio per il
98/99% che ho e quindi io non lo so se
il successo porta alla felicità però una
cosa vi posso dire che con questi tre
pilastri disciplina relazione e
gratitudine vi posso dire che la
felicità porta al successo Grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]